rita grise et à 83 ans
son quotidien commence toujours par
faire le plein de nouvelles sur la
pandémie qui a bien failli l'emporter
il y a deux semaines moi j'étais à mézin
choc n'a pas relation manille quelqu'un
lui à l'entraînement d'hier l'obtenir
j'ai été nul je le dis elle et son mari
ont été hospitalisés à deux jours
d'écart pour difficultés respiratoires
toux deux reçoivent leur diagnostic
infection à la coved 19 mais rien pour
la déstabiliser je pose ici que j'ai une
bonne santé puis vint pratiquement pas
[Musique]
prescrit de la morphine jude sinon moi
j'ai pas vu un plan des charges riche
que que j'avais besoin pour la femme
énergique quel est ce n'était pas
toujours facile de tuer l'ennui et le
cheval telle la porte de rachat jusqu'à
finale d'un tee shirt à manches et un
cas ce que tu veux mon fils me dit maman
depuis vendredi et les de retour dans la
maison familiale avec son fils qui
veille sur elle pendant une semaine
j'avais mes deux paires d'inquiéter à
l'hôpital en même temps dans deux
hôpitaux différents toujours qui serait
la première personne à avoir eu on ne
sait pas ma mère aussi dû subir une
chirurgie au courant du mois de mars
alors presque à l'hôpital peut-être que
par mégarde sa réponse est plus simple
est une cause si rita a survécu aux
coronavirus malheureusement roger 83 ans
l'amour de sa vie n'a pas eu la même
chance
non mais n'importe quel jour est ce que
est ce que vous avez pu le voir une
dernière fois vous avez pas pu on part
décédé le 9 avril via zoom le médecin
nous a permis de voir mon pain pendant
qu'il est encore dans le coma et j'ai pu
lui dire quelques mots
j'espère qu'ils m'ont entendu je pensais
pas que ça faisait au temps de bien des
compagnies quelqu'un jusqu'à la fin
comme bien des enfants qui se retrouvent
devant le même casse-tête dans cette
crise qui frappe énormément les
personnes âgées
genre grise et a dû faire un choix
déménager de montréal pour s'occuper de
sa mère dans le petit village familial
on a envisagé de la place et quelque
part je regardais les nouvelles et je me
disais mais dans quel environnement
qu'on va la placer mon champ l'appareil
comment puis-je vous aider et je peux
plus gentil qu'un autre sûr que je me
suis réveillé un matin je dis bien j'ai
pas de conjoint
j'ai vraiment faim mon patron m'a acheté
un ordinateur neuf pour faire du
télétravail
le fait que tu peux m'occuper de ma mère
ça m'aide aussi à vivre mon deuil pour
mon père parce que la vie après tout
continue je vous souhaite une excellente
journée
mon fichu montante tabbee est bien
proche de 100 je suis positive puis-je
mais n'y a pas bon dos mais je suis
aujourd'hui
puis je profite de ce que je suis
capable femmes pour l'instant rita et
son fils s'adapte à cette nouvelle
situation impossible de fixer une date
pour la suite des choses
il faudra être patient je pense pas que
c'est un bon temps pour aller commencer
à magasiner des foyers pour personnes
âgées pour la crise se trompera on
regardera quelles sont les options un
jour là fo entre les préparatifs des
funérailles et sa nouvelle vie
temporaire jean grise et y voit une
occasion allah ni maître pense que c'est
une bonne chose de profiter de ce temps
de de quiétude qu'on a de l'inter qui
est quelques semaines providence parce
qu'on n'arrête pas de courir tout en moi
je m'occupe de ma mère avec mes frères
et soeurs aussi que même beaucoup une
sagesse et un positivisme dont il peut
faire profiter celle qui lui a transmis
ses qualités si précieuse en ces temps
de pandémie